[Música]
cuando iba al colegio allá en los
míticos y mitificados años 80 tenía una
profesora la maestra como me gusta más
decir
hay que mantener esa palabra en vigor la
de maestra y maestro doña carmen que me
decía que de mayor sería periodista
y me llamaba el reportero que me iba a
decir a mí que años después se
estudiaría periodismo me gustaría me
doctor haría en periodismo y media de
cara a esta profesión
años más tarde también tuve la suerte de
dedicarme a la docencia y en estas dos
pasiones en estas dos profesiones me
muevo pero lejos de parecer una suerte
de bipolaridad lo del periodismo la
comunicación y la educación creo que son
dos disciplinas que deben ir mucho más
de la mano de lo que van
porque porque vivimos en un mundo que
una sociedad conocida como sociedad de
la información rodeados de estímulos
informativos rodea de notificaciones
siempre con la pantallita pantallita
pantallita
las fake news pero sin embargo no
estamos trabajando desde la educación un
buen conocimiento un buen consumo de los
medios
comunicar según la primera excepción de
la real academia es hacer a una persona
partícipe de lo que se tiene
fijaros qué definición tan bonita
fijaros en qué gesto más generoso hay
algo más generoso que compartir lo que
tenemos y si lo que tenemos es nuestro
conocimiento no es eso lo que hace un
profesor entonces yo creo que comunicar
y educar tienen que ir mucho más de la
mano
pero en esa sociedad en la que recibimos
tantísimos estímulos y la que el
profesor se enfrenta a niños a jóvenes a
generación alguna generación conocida
como centenial en la que están
recibiendo todos esos estímulos
continuamente donde están inmersos en
esas armas de distracción masiva que son
las redes sociales y las pantallitas de
los móviles como consigue un profesor
llamar la atención puede conectar un
profesor con esos alumnos con esos
centenial sin ser un buen comunicador
yo creo que todos si pensamos y hacemos
el ejercicio y pensáis en los profesores
que os han dejado huella seguro que
todos estaría de acuerdo conmigo en que
todos eran buenos comunicadores no se
puede ser un buen profesor sin ser un
buen comunicador sin poder hacer
partícipes y poder transmitir el
conocimiento
sin embargo como digo educación y
comunicación han ido por carriles
separados hay una disciplina que se
llama educomunicación un campo mejor
dicho del conocimiento que es la de
comunicación que yo cuando hablo en los
colegios y les hablo de tu comunicación
incluso cuando hablo en periodismo de tu
comunicación prácticamente nadie ha oído
hablar de la palabra educomunicación sin
embargo es una disciplina que desde los
años 70 incluso antes en latinoamérica y
en francia principalmente pues lleva
trabajando investigando y estudiando
sobre cómo trabajar estos dos
territorios tan necesario de que
trabajen juntos
educación y comunicación o la
educomunicación será conocido de
distintas formas educación en materia
comunicación didáctica de los medios
comunicación educativa
pero al final digamos el concepto de
consenso de consenso es la
educomunicación
desde que campos o que enfoques se le ha
dado pues desde la perspectiva más
anglosajón aún se ha estudiado de una
forma más instrumental es decir la
educación en los medios cómo funcionan
los medios enseñar a los estudiantes a
los niños y niñas cómo funcionan los
medios de comunicación una educación con
los medios es decir utilizó los medios
de comunicación como una herramienta más
de trabajo todos vemos los que tenemos
niños en el cole que trabajan con los
periódicos con las revistas con noticias
entonces eso es trabajar educación con
los medios y por último una tercera
perspectiva que yo creo que es también
más necesaria que nunca es la educación
frente a los medios es estimular un
consumo responsable de los medios
despertando el espíritu crítico es decir
como podemos
y combatir esa cantidad de noticias
falsas cómo podemos discernir lo que
está bien y lo que está mal si no
educamos a los niños para que hagan ese
consumo responsable hemos visto que los
centros educativos hay campañas de todo
tipo campañas para hábitos saludables de
comer fruta verdura pescado de reciclar
de la sostenibilidad del planeta del no
consumo de comida chatarra del consumo
por supuesto de alcohol y drogas pero
sin embargo no hay campañas sobre un
consumo responsable un consumo y un uso
responsable de los medios de
comunicación
estas competencias todas ellas están
incluidas en el currículum de primaria y
secundaria cuando aquí tengo compañeros
del ámbito de la educación que saben
perfectamente lo que es la lingüística
lo que es la competencia lingüística la
digital la social la cívica e incluso la
iniciativa emprendedora creo que todas
ellas se pueden trabajar desde la
competencia mediática y ahí es donde
también creo que también se produce una
verdadera innovación cuando utilizamos
los medios de comunicación para
desarrollar todas esas competencias que
son necesarias tanto en primaria como en
secundaria
estamos además
viendo como ya el consumidor no es un
sujeto el estudiante o cualquier persona
no es un sujeto pasivo de la información
cualquiera con su móvil con su ordenador
puede generar contenido un niño y los
niños están continuamente con tik tok la
cualquiera está subiendo ahora mismo
contenido a las redes sociales entonces
no estamos ante un consumidor de
información estamos ante un consumidor
que también es productor y ahí es el
concepto en inglés de prosumer o de
pro prosumidor en un castellano más un
poco forzado
entonces yo os quería comentar y
compartir alguna experiencia que estamos
llevando a cabo de investigación
utilizando los medios de comunicación
concretamente en asturias con radios
escolares en asturias antes tener una
radio escolar era muy costoso había
colegios colegios buenos de pago como se
decía por aquel entonces que tenían
podían disponer de un equipo de radio
tener un equipo de radio era complicado
es costoso manejarlo es difícil
incluso emitir estar legislado está
regulador del 101 puedes poner una
emisora de radio porque si no pero había
experiencias de radio escolar ahora
mismo y por hoy cualquiera con un
ordenador con un
el micrófono y con una conexión de
internet puede hacer una radio escolar
vivimos además un momento que es la edad
dorada de la radio gracias al podcasting
plataformas como eye box plataformas
como spotify o como itunes han disparado
el consumo de este tipo de audios
hemos visto a través de esta
investigación en las radios escolares de
asturias que están agrupadas en un grupo
que se llaman
errequeerre un nombre bastante ingenioso
pues como las competencias que hemos
visto todas las competencias que hemos
visto se ven mejoradas incrementadas al
preguntarles a los profesores que han
trabajado en estos proyectos
entonces trabajar con esta innovación
utilizando los medios hace que también
hagamos un mejor consumo de los medios
de comunicación esto es una campaña de
que llevó a cabo la federación de
asociaciones de periodismo de españa que
sin periodismo no hay democracia
ciudadanos y sin niños y estudiantes
futuros ciudadanos que no estén bien
formados en el uso de los medios de
comunicación tampoco podremos conseguir
un buen periodismo y por tanto una
saludable democracia y bueno ahora para
no enfadar a doña carmen me marcho
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]